okay so I just had like the best money
on my life
so I just spent the morning talking to
Rick who's my contact here is the head
of communication sorry I literally burst
of light because of his amazing stories
about the animals that Rick could he was
an extra in Game of Thrones it turns out
watch season 1 he's a wildly we've been
talking about the different animals
we're gonna be working with I'm gonna be
going into the enclosures with tamarins
on the bat going behind the scenes of
reptiles we already went behind the
scenes ash went into the bet here that I
just brought in a given no Lina not
given
it's just overwhelming really it's been
incredible another chance to get much
footage but I did just do really really
interesting interviews brick for like
half an hour that was too windy for you
to hear me
I seem to pick the week where Jersey
becomes in the holiday park right now
what I'm going to be doing is going and
filming everything that weaves the stuff
for both my channel and for that channel
so montage
so I just found out that if you put up a
tripod near a gorilla the gorilla will
think of the bat tripod is a blowgun and
will go mental
whoops fortunately didn't ask for
anything at me this time because they
have been known to throw things like poo
people they don't like I just get some
really nice footage of orangutan
possibly my favorite thing here actually
I'm just kind of trying to film
everything today because this is all
going to be role for the dull stuff I'm
sure
so this behind me you can tell that it's
built to radiate heat in a ecologically
friendly mapping in the summer so they
all forms of natural insulation they've
got bottles in the walls and tires of
the Wolves and they also fluids nuns had
a wood chip back the wood chip burner as
I was talking to Rick earlier and found
out burns there's another large-bore as
they keep in that bedding King comes
from shredded office paper so they're
trending towards be incredibly
self-sufficient here him I think the
eventual goal is they just want to shut
the gate survive regardless of nuclear
Armageddon you know they're they grow
them food they grow their own fuel
they're working on water and power at
moment it's my kind of place
I feel like I should say something very
profound because I have a second camera
mate wouldn't y'all kill me literally
filming me filming town now I can film
me filming me filming me
and basically trying to get the shots of
their in-flight because think about this
ponytail is it's actually very long it's
for about 30 meters long and they have
space to action fly and they look
amazing when they do it you know there's
weeks back so okay so the wife of what
have my childhood here is just came in
and asked how my filming was going so
there's that as in Jarrett orals
Widow Lee I've met this morning briefly
and I just walked into the game now so
yeah also the bats have been completely
lean a Philly man for the past about 20
minutes I've been filming pretty much
non-stop because they've just booked
just bet do you hear that I love the
sound of these bats
so behind me like there these are still
away see crested black macaques they're
barely invented primate and I had no
adorable God's Idol lighting is terrible
where's my vlogging manners that's oh
wow I just let slate it now I'm talk to
you Ivanova
what problem our been having over and
over again on this trip is that and this
is such a camera nerd like point but
it's my channel supposed to be so many
animals are really dark like gorillas
macaques bats and it's very difficult to
get you exposure settings such that you
expose the animal just as well as there
the background sky it's going to help
the situation because no one's gonna see
this but probably Oh several weeks it's
been really annoying
so this behind me is the reason that all
this is here this is Gerald Donald well
it's not the statue of Gerald oh this
has been here ever since I first came
here as a kid
as he loved the statue in this man was
hugely influential means the kid this
man changed where I think about animals
which may be changed changed where I
think about the world
because of him all of this is here you
know you talk to any every person
everyone is so passionate about the work
they do here and so many people were
inspired by him and his books
you know he it's an individual that
believed in something passionately and
followed through on that belief and he
changed the world exactly the kind of
person I want to be one day
but
this place is about to close up but
guests so what about time I may leave
and let Haman
tonight right touch party work
yeah
so if you want if you want to film them
feeding on that brunch